hello everyone my name is Devin
tachycardia and in this two-part
presentation
Oliver Rubin colleague and myself will
give you a fairly thorough introduction
to solving partial differential
equations in the Wolfram language Oliver
and both are members of the kernel
development group over here were from
research but we have slightly different
interests I am a mathematician and I
work on symbolic solutions of
differential equations
while Oliver has an engineering
background and works on numerical
solutions of differential equations so
I'll go first and speak about symbolic
solutions of partial differential
equations and then Oliver will come in
and speak about numerical solutions of
PDS
using the finite element method so
hopefully between the two of us will do
a pretty nice overview of the whole
field
ok so here is a more detailed plan for
my talk so I'll begin with talking about
first order please and I've chosen the
transport equation the scalar
conservation law and the klara equation
to illustrate in this class of theories
later on we clear to you that even these
first-order pd's offer a lot of
complexity now if this were a course on
partial differential equations it will
be very important to talk about the
classical PDS so I'll also talk about
the classical P DS maybe the wave
equation the heat equation and the
Laplace equation now the field of P DS
has continually evolved into modern
times so I've chosen for modern periods
for today's talk enemy the burgers
equation from fluid dynamics the
black-scholes equation from finance the
Schrodinger equation in quantum
mechanics and finally the KTV equation
from sautron theory now at the heart of
many solution techniques for PDS are the
so called sturm-liouville problems which
are basically eigenvalue problems for
differential equations and so I will
show you how to solve these with D solve
but in practical applications
it is often more convenient to work
directly with the eigen systems of a
differential operator so I'll do that
using the dying system in the last part
of our talk
okay so let's begin with the first order
P DS and the transport equation so the
transport equation is an example of a
linear first-order PD now you can find a
general solution of this equation the d
solve and what you get back is a
travelling wave kind of solution but
this over here is an arbitrary function
in the general solution so to find the
particular solution what you could do is
to give an initial value and once you
have done that then you get back a
particular solution of the transport
equation and finally what you can do is
you can animate the solution in
Mathematica and you see this is wave
traveling to the right it's a very
simple kind of solution but the
transport equation itself is quite
fundamental to the whole area okay so
now I going to ski the conservation law
so the scalar conservation law is a
quasi linear first order PDE so this
over here is the crazy linear term but
even in this case if you try and find
general solution you get it back in
implicit form and that means that in
general it is rather difficult to solve
the scalar conservation law and get
particular solutions but it can do it
for example with this very simple set of
initial data and then you get back a
simple solution of the scalar
conservation law and finally we go on to
the Claro equation which is an example
of a nonlinear first-order PD so that's
the Claro equation it's got three terms
x times a first partial derivative and
then Y times another partial derivative
and that is the nonlinear term okay so
it turns out that for non in a PDS the
best kind of solution is a so-called
complete integral so let's find it over
here and these all complains that this
is a nonlinear PD so it is trying to
build a special solution and this
special solution is based on parameters
c1 and c2 it looks rather simple but
then remind yourself that in fact this
is a two parameter family of planes and
so what you could do is you could
actually let's say fix c1 and then let's
see to be a function of c1 and what you
then get is a one parameter family of
planes and then the envelope of this one
parameter family would be another
solution for the PD so let's see that
geometrically so the animation shows you
over here now that the orange planes can
rotate to give you the envelope solution
and this is exactly how these all solves
the initial value problem over here and
you get back a particular solution okay
we numb over to the classical PDS and
let's begin with the wave equation so
the wave equation is an example of a
linear hyperbolic equation what that
means is it's really good for studying
the propagation of signals of all kinds
and in particular if the signal has a
discontinuity to start then that must be
propagated all the way and to see that
let's look at a black string over here
so for the black string let's say we
assume that both ends of the string
remain fixed ring vibrations that's a
good assumption we then pluck the string
let's say one third of the way from the
left and once we've done that we let the
system go and this all can then solve
the wave equation with these conditions
now there are many available techniques
in this area but for this particular
example these are chooses the separation
of variables method because that gives a
nice textbook like solution
to the problem but it is rather
difficult integration so it does take a
bit of time but when it's done you'll
see you get back an inactive sum and
inactive infinite sum in fact of
elementary solutions of the very
equation so this solution is what we can
then use to study the plug string in
greater detail so there's a solution
over there you can pick out let's say
one return from it and then you can
visualize the vibrating string with an
animation so that is the animation for a
vibrating plucked string now notice that
although this is a hard problem
the symbolic solution is a very complete
solution because of lots of information
and therefore is pretty useful in this
case okay so now gone to the heat
equation and the heat equation is an
example of a parabolic PD now roughly
speaking that means is that this
equation is going to smear out
information it's going to make things
smoother and nicer as time goes by and
to see that let's consider the case of
the flow of heat and a bar that is
insulated at both the ends so let's
specify first that no heat flows through
the ends of the bar and next let's give
an initial temperature at different
points on the bar initially so let's say
when X is zero then temperature is 20
when X is 1 the temperature is 100 and
then you solve the heat equation with
these conditions and again the choice of
method over here is the separation of
variables you get back an infinite sum
of solutions you pick up let's say the
first 10 terms over there and then
finally when you visualize it you see
that that is the initial data over here
and then very quickly the solution set
us down to its steady state value of 60
degrees so the heat equation is quite
important in all kinds of applications
and finally the Laplace equation which
is used to study steady states basically
so that's the Laplace equation I'll give
a dirichlet condition on a rectangle and
then what I do is I use D solve and
separation of variables to solve it I
let's say pick out the first 300 terms
and then we visualize a solution in a
rectangle and there are some remarkable
features of the solution the first point
is that originally problem over here is
well posed there is a nice solution to
it and that itself is a hard
mathematical theorem next all of the
boundary conditions are kind of sharp
and have sharp features the solution
itself is nice and smooth so that is a
particular property of these so-called
elliptic equations and finally notice
that the extrema do not occur in the
middle but they only occur at the
boundary and there's a saddle point in
the middle so this is a another nice
feature of elliptic equations so a
Laplace equation is important from a
conceptual and practical point of view
ok so now move on to modern P DS and
let's begin with the burgers equation
from fluid dynamics so bogus equation
was proposed or in 1940 as a model for
turbulence so this is a burgers equation
the epsilon over here is really the
viscosity for the fluid and when burgers
proposed it he hoped to provide a very
simple model for turbulence now if you
provide proposed a model for turbulence
the last thing you want is for someone
tell you that your problem has an exact
solution and it's exactly what happened
ten years later Hopf and Cole showed
that the burgers equation could in fact
be reduced to the heat equation by
transformation so let's see this
remarkable solution with some piecewise
data over here and when you solve D
solve that community solve value over
here because that's a little easier to
look at
internal solutions the solution comes
from a rather difficult integration but
the error functional here the ER F tells
you that you really have a heat equation
kind of solution and the nice thing is
that this solution is smooth for any
positive values epsilon on the other
hand when you start passing to zero and
make the cups are smaller then you do
see a shock discontinue developing as
you see over here and that is the
typical feature of these nonlinear pd's
that you can have shock phenomena
occurring in some limiting case okay so
I now go into the black-scholes equation
which was proposed by Blackman shows
from 1973 as a model for option value
financing and perception in finance
okay so black and Scholes realize that
they equation two could be reduced to
the heat equation so when you solve this
equation in Mathematica you get back a
solution and that solution has got again
error functions inside it what you could
do now is to actually give some
particular values to the parameters and
get back an option price and just to
make sure things are okay you get to
financial derivative with similar values
and you get back exactly the same answer
so it is to me is rather remarkable that
such a closed form symbolic formula has
got so much importance in a very
practical applied situation and even
more that it all comes from the simple
heat equation which we looked at early
on okay now in modern times the
Schrodinger equation has a quite large
importance because it models quantum
mechanics so in fact to here we have the
two dimensional Schrodinger equation for
a quantum particle free to move within a
two dimensional rectangular the
mysterious I over there which plays a
big role in solutions so what I do is I
prescribe some initial conditions in
fact over here I've got a sum of states
has the initial condition
and then what I can do is prescribe
boundary conditions to say that it's all
zero and boundary
I saw the boundary only problem and all
that happens is that the initial States
cannot get mixed up so you have some
kind of entanglement taking place now
it's all difficult to work with these
complex valued solutions so Max Born
taught us that in such a case what you
do is move over to so-called probably
density to actually get some kind of
physical picture of what is happening so
that is a problem density Rho and they
can visualize it using plot 3d that's a
hard animation but it will come up in
just a minute
and then when it happens you see that
the particle wanders all over the box
and some kind of non deterministic
manner according to Schrodinger equation
so that's a very pretty picture based on
some work done by my colleague eat I
said you okay as a final example of a
modern PD let's look at the KTV equation
which is a knowledge of PD but the
remarkable thing is that this PD is in
some sense completely integrable which
means that one can find lots of solution
of the equation and they have some
remarkable properties so for example D
solve can find so-called cranberry
solutions of this equation so again it
complains they're trying to build a
special solution and the special
solution has got parameters C 1 C 2 and
C 3 unit what we can then do is you can
obtain a particular solution by giving
values to these constants C 1 C 2 and C
3
now this over here is a rather
remarkable particular solution so
historically in the 1834 the engineer
Scott Russell was riding his horse along
the Edinburgh canal and he noticed a
kind of solitary wave which was moving
along he cheated and horseback for about
a mile and then lost it in the windings
of the canal he came back wrote of his
work and what you see over here now in
the animation
exactly the kind of wave that Scott
Russell saw on that day in 1834 so he
solitary waves are absolutely crucial
for many applications and I believe that
the last word in them has not been said
as yet they will continue to be
important in the future as well okay so
now we go little deeper into the
so-called
Sturm little problems so in the 1830s
the French mathematician still malleable
started looking at qualitative theory of
differential equations so they were not
really interested in solving a
differential equation but trying to
understand some general features of a
differential equation so as an example
what they did here the so called Drishti
problem for this rather simple equation
y double prime plus lambda y equal to
zero those are directly conditions they
just say that the function y is zero at
both the ends and if you ask me sort of
solve the problem it tells you that
there are solutions there are
non-trivial solutions only for a very
limited number of values of lambda
namely lambda I'd better be a perfect
square so here are the first five eigen
functions sine X sine 2x plus sine 5x
and then what you can do is you can plot
these eigen functions so the
traditionary problem is a very simple
example of a sturm-liouville problem now
you could also prescribe derivatives at
both ends that's the so called non
problem so here I say that Y prime is 0
at both the ends and you get back a
solution in terms of cosine again you
can find the first five eigen functions
so the one over here is of course also a
solution in this case and you can plot
them so those are two basic eigen value
problems for differential equations now
slightly harder than that is the
so-called Robin problem where you have a
combination of
derivatives and values at one or both
the end so if you give to desolder soul
in this case what you notice is that the
eigen value equation is a transcendental
equation so it's quite hard to solve it
in general but what you could do is to
give a specific range to the parameter
lambda over here and when you do that
and do let's say a plot the type over
here notice that the eigenvalue equation
has roots somewhere close to 4 and close
to 8 the question is how do you obtain
this solution using TESOL itself well it
was for this purpose that we have the
assumption option so if you tell D solve
find the eigen values eigen functions in
that particular range then it does come
back with an answer but what you see
over here is this root object which
looks a bit strange because got an in
exact number in it and one has come to
believe that D solve and dissolve value
both work only with exact concerts but
in fact these eigen values are really
exact and you can work out let's say the
first 10,000 place of decimal in this
case quite quickly so what you see over
here is that we have a very complete
solution to the Robin problem obtained
by specifying a range for the eigenvalue
parameter so strongly all problems of
course foundational very important but
in practice you really want to have only
a few Augen values and eigen functions
and so we now talk about so called
differential eigen systems and in fact
the di consistent function which wasn't
just recently does just that for you so
for example suppose I want to find the
first four eigen value eigen functions
of the laplacian with dirichlet
conditions the Dayang system does that
for you in a flash you get back the
eigen values a 1 4 9 and 16 you get back
the eigen functions and then you can
visualize the eigen functions
before there's a very nice application
of DNC system let's look at the quantum
harmonic oscillator so the corner
harmonic oscillator is very similar to
the classical oscillator but the eigen
value eigen functions are now much more
fundamental so here's the first few
eigen value eigen functions obtained
with the eigen system so that's the
Likert ladder of eigenvalues and climb
the ladder from left to right now that's
all very static so what you could do is
to breathe some life into it with some
time dependence which is what I do over
here then again we follow Max Born and
more the Prada density and having done
that you can then visualize the prod
enca t over time so that is a quantum
harmonic oscillator solved using version
11 okay now beyond Odie's there are very
nice icon systems for p d--'s and
particularly laplace equation for the
laplace operator so here is a laplacian
in a rectangle you have d'origine
conditions i look for the first let's
see 8 i can value eigen function the
rectangle that's the rectangle over here
and then I look at the values which are
integers and you notice there's some
redundancy over here some degeneracy
over here and those are the eigen
functions which are basically kind of
products off I can functions for the 1d
laplacian so what you can do is you can
then visualize them and you get back
this very pretty set of eigenfunctions
for the laplacian in a rectangle you can
also do the same thing for let's say a
cylinder so that's the Laplace equation
the Laplace operator in a cylinder of
radius 2 and next what you can do is you
can ask for the eigen system with the
first seven wise eigen functions
the eigenvalues in this case are in fact
zeros Bessel functions you can see over
here and the eigen functions are
combinations of Triggs and Bessel
functions now we have a nice new
function which is recently less densely
brought 3d which gives a very pretty
picture of let's say the seventh
eigenfunction so let's just wait for
that to come up over here but what we
get back is a very pretty
heigen function for the laplacian in a
cylinder composed of Craig's and Bessel
functions and as my final example for
today's talk I'm going to talk about the
vibrations of a circular drum now that's
a well known problem but typically what
you talk about is the case we hit the
drum right in the middle so a few weeks
ago John Schneider who's an expert user
of Mathematica wrote to me to say that
in fact he had solved it for the case
where you can distract it from at
somewhere between the center and the
periphery
so John's method is to start the
laplacian in 2d with the rishtey
conditions on a your disc and then
having found the eigenvalues and eigen
functions with Bessel zeros and Bessel
functions he then evolves these eigen
value eigen functions in time and using
the first 128 eigen functions and some
very nice smoothing properties he
actually managed to get a beautiful
animation of a circular drumhead when it
is struck off the axis somewhere near
the boundary so let's run the animation
over here this is actually remarkable at
least to me
so here the animation you see that's the
circular drum which has been struck off
axes this tells me that really the eigen
system is a very successful function it
can show you this very detailed
intricate behavior of something as
simple as a circular drum
okay so I'm clearly at the end of my
presentation but just to give you a hint
of what's gonna come in the future where
we are working integral transforms in
fact at the moment we're working on the
huncle transform and we also would like
to have some more support for green
functions in PDS
so that's a set of directions which is
kind of very mathematical and important
for the future for symbolic solutions of
PDS on their end for applications we
also need to support periodic boundary
conditions which are important for many
applications and other geometry regions
beyond just once we support now but
luckily in both these cases Oliver has
done a fantastic job of providing
support in the eigen system and in be
solved so at this point I'll conclude my
talk and hand over to him it's been a
great pleasure to speak with you and I'm
really excited to have been able to show
you all this wonderful functionality in
version 11 so at this point is stop and
thank you very much